in terms of human ancestry genomic data  has helped reinforce the theory that  humans have spread out across the globe  from africa and the recent past this has  led to a large number of variants that  are shared across the globe and  fluctuate and only subtle levels those  fluctuations though are very Geographic  in their nature such that individuals  are closer together have much more  similar allele frequencies and that can  be used to reconstruct population  movements and even individual level  ancestry of where someone's grandparents  or great-grandparents come from the  other major signal that we've been  learning about using genomic data is  about how the human population has been  growing in many places throughout the  globe and that growth has been tied with  the appearance of many new rare variants  that are geographically localized  and an exciting area is using those rare  variants to uncover very recent time  period migration patterns  you